نشهد بعض
التغييرات المثيرة للإعجاب عندما تقول
رؤية بعض التغييرات المثيرة للإعجاب ، ما
الذي تقصده أن الأطفال الذين
كان سلوكهم العدواني يوميًا وذهب بعيدًا ،
أعني أنه ذهب بعيدًا ،
أصبح الكثير من الأطفال أكثر
اجتماعية ،
لذلك حصلنا
على بندقية في قبلة
ما هو اللون الأرجواني الذي يسهل
إعادة توجيهه ، يمكنني العمل ، يمكنني نوعًا ما مثل
اقتراح مثل ، دعنا نفعل هذا أو
نفعل هذا وسيذهب على ما يرام أو نعم ، أمي
أو أوكي دوكي إزرا هو أكثر صبرًا لا
يضرب ليس مثيرًا لدينا  للمشاركة ،
حسنًا ، يمكنني الالتحاق بالمدرسة ، نعم ،
ما الذي تفعله الآن تعال إلى
هنا وفي المنزل يفعل أشياء
لم تحلم بها جوان أبدًا
مثل الطهي
[الموسيقى
] والغناء
] ما الذي يدور في ذهنك
في هذه المرحلة
أنا  استعد طفلي ،
سأستعيد ابني ، يمكننا إعداد الديناصورات ، ولكن كما تعلمون ، كان هناك
شيء ما يزال مزعجًا ، هل
تعتقد أن
توقعاتك تؤثر على طريقة اعتقادك أنه يفعل
نعم ولا ومونتيس  أوري ، لا أعرف
كيف بدأ
يتغير ، لا أعرف كيف بدأ في
التواصل ، لا أعرف كيف
بدأ في أن يكون عقلانيًا كيف توقف
عن العدوانية